my level was not that job I mean I think
there are some Republicans who have
principal differences with Ron Paul who
we think his foreign policy is reckless
for instance or do you think the gold
standard is impractical or I mean I it's
fair to believe that as far as I'm
concerned I have questions about his
foreign policy and disagree with it to
some extent I haven't given a political
speech for quite some time now
and but I felt that this was the
occasion to come out of retirement why
as the United States Department of
Justice not charge this election in
terms of 9/11 well that's kind of the
genius in the pitfall the basic pitfall
of what Ron Paul is done I mean it's
such a loose affiliation of groups you
know it's sort of anybody who kind of
wants to join can and that's a great
thing but maybe in the long term not a
great organizing principle for a
political movement a picture amazingly
all the charges the Embassy of 98 and
all this other stuff is all listed but
ironically nothing - left side is
extremely disturbing changed our entire
I mean III remember you know saying when
I was riding around with him for this
story you know we'll gee I think that
sounds like a very bad idea to something
he opinion he offered and he said well
it's okay not everyone has to agree on
Paul is appealing because he refuses to
lead because he refuses to command he
refused tell other people what to do
it's not just ideological it's
temperamental like that's who he is as a
person and he can't help it
and so Ron Paul will never get up and
say you do this you follow me he's just
that's not who he is and that's what
people like him but because that's not
who I mean you have to be that guy in
order to organize an efficient movement
revolution
if I see him over the next two to three
years if I see it start to rise up and
if this country shows me that it's worth
it for me to do it
if we